Ben Reiter is with Sports Illustrated
senior writer author of Astro ball the
new way to win it all and of course he
predicted on the cover of Sports
Illustrated the Astros would win the
2017 World Series three years before it
happened
big show-off here who do you have
winning this year Ben I picked the
Astros again
oh I'm doubling down I did it actually
stupidly on November 2nd everyone was
like look dude you can never make a
prediction again like you have to ride
this one ride it out well the night
before in my column for si.com I already
predicted a repeat that's kind of
feeling myself but if I said you could
do a redo I'm sticking with them ok look
at that pitching staff man I mean I
don't think people are quite realizing
how that pitching staffs going to play
in October when you can shorten it I
mean it's a historic are they the best
team in baseball though are they just
better equipped for October than anybody
else I think they are the best team
baseball perhaps not right now with all
Tuesday out in Korea out and Springer
out I mean that hurts but yeah top to
bottom I think they are again but look
man playoffs anything can happen you can
see wildcard team getting through that
short series it's a crapshoot really all
right but you also you talk about the
new way to win it all and is it a new
way to win it all when you look at what
the Florida Marlins did when they won a
couple of World Series titles where it
felt like there was a four or five year
window then you take the wrecking ball
to it dismantle and then build it back
up weren't the Marlins doing with the
Astros and the Cubs did but years ago
there's some level but it's it goes far
beyond the tanking or as the Astros
would say not investing in a team that
is not going to win right away which is
how they how they pose that question
it's really about how they made the
decisions that they rebuilt the team
like after they were bad how do you
build it back up and the pendulum had
swung very far towards money ball
towards analytics towards running your
team by computer ever since Moneyball
came out in 2003 the Astro stroke of
genius as I dig into in the book was
bringing back in the human element
recognizing humans are flawed
they're biased but they can pick up
things that computers can't that
algorithms can't figure out a way to
synthesize them to guide their decision
making that's the that's the big idea in
the book wait wait you explain that okay
well look like Scouts had come at
falling out of favor you remember in
Moneyball right Brad Pitt said
one side of the table the crusty old
Scouts are on the other side of the
table going on and on about what the
guy's girlfriend looks like and things
like that I mean that's where we were
right like the primacy of Brad Pitt
obviously because he's Brad Pitt over
the Scouts the primacy of numbers over
human gut instinct human observation the
Astra's said look like yes we're gonna
push analytics as far as you can go but
to get the real edge we have to go back
to the scouts figure out how to use that
information so it's really combining new
school and old school to up to move
things forward I have a problem with
Moneyball let's hear it at no point in
the movie do they mention they have one
of the great young pitching steps so we
we give credit to Billy Beane Brad Pitt
a Scott Hatteberg at no point should
they go we got we got huh t you got
molder in there you got Zito in there
come on Suzie Isringhausen I might have
been in the bullpen
that's why Moneyball worked because you
had one of the best rotations best young
rotations that we've seen in a decade
and of course it all ultimately didn't
work as Billy said mice my stuff doesn't
work in the playoffs right yes he said
for the Astros first of all I mean I do
write about Correia and Altuve and
Springer and Verlander in this book but
it also worked right yeah they won the
idea is like how they developed those
players how they even drafted us players
nobody expected them to draft carlos
correa first overall in 2012 out of
Puerto Rico which hadn't produced a good
player in a long time the number if you
went by numbers alone you wouldn't have
taken him based largely on the track
record of Puerto Rican players it was
very bad that was a scouting call really
like the numbers did support that yeah
maybe there's something in this guy that
we haven't seen recently from the island
but that was a real scouting call they
met Caray they learned how when he was 8
years old he asked his parents to send
him to a bilingual school so that when
he was a baseball star
he'd be able to give his interviews in
English like that's the sort of drive
you know that a computer can't pick up
but scouts can and that's why the
Astra's kind of realized that there's
value in the human element as well and
the numbers can't describe everything
but did the cub supplying Astro ball
where they
would they be you know doing the same
kind of yeah than a blueprint here
similar concepts they didn't have to do
it to such a depth obviously because
they have some advantages being in
Chicago they had kind of a better system
when they started Jeff Luna had nothing
really in the cupboard I mean yes
Springer was in the low miner striking
out a ton Kaiko is maybe gonna be like a
fifth number five command and control
guy possibly Altuve Oh a nice slap
hitting middle infielder beyond that
there nothing in the major league level
at the worst ranked minor league
organization farm system I should say so
yeah I mean this is why they had to do
it to such a depth and with such a
purity and really pushing to the
bleeding edge of innovation in baseball
in sports fan riders book is a strobe
all the senior writer for Sports
Illustrated who predicted the Astros
would win the World Series three years
before it happened also you pick the
Cubs to win the World Series beating the
Indians and you said they'd do it in
five so two games off but still you got
it right
that's how bad people have been asking
me to predict all sorts of things like
they think I know stuff now right like
Powerball numbers stock picks one guy
came up to me at an event he was like
can you tell me when I'm going to have a
child and I was like my understanding
dude is that that's up to you I'm not
sure so again I did pick the Astros to
repeat but uh I'm not sure I should be
making it too many other predictions
immediately anyway Bryce Harper was not
traded because why because I think that
the Nationals couldn't bring themselves
to give up on you know this is the
seventh year of them being an elite team
they haven't made it past the league the
LDS once right I think when push came to
shove like are we really going to just
give up on this project that seemed like
would produce multiple World Series
champions hasn't even produced an NLCS
appearance
I don't think emotionally they could
bring themselves to do it I'm also not
sure the return was there like yesyes
Bryce Harper
he's also hitting about 220 with the
Wins Above Replacement of 0.5 so are you
gonna blow up like your last chance
perhaps in this cycle for maybe not a
great return for Bryce Harper I get it
maybe not something the Astros would
have done if they're in the same
situation but
I get it on an emotional level for the
Nationals but if we look back on this
let's say Bryce Harper and Scott Boras
yo you know what we're gonna go where
the money takes us here and we're not
gonna stay in Washington DC do you think
Nationals fans will look back on this
trade deadline decision and go aye
it's better that we rode this out
instead of trade for him like I it
almost feels like the Nationals know
that this could happen and that they're
sort of bracing for for Bryce Harper not
being there so let's see what happens
second half of the season and in all it
if he leaves we at least got seven years
out of him yeah I think that was the
decision really and I can't blame them I
really can't like when you've been
building for so long you do have you
know 190 million dollar team with
multiple times say Young award-winner on
it Bryce Harper you know Dan and Murphy
you've got the greatest phenom and
baseball right now Juan Soto like yeah
I'd give it two more months you know
it's not like the Braves and Phillies
have been great but they don't have a
track record who knows if they'll be
able to carry it through you know part
of baseball part of sports is not
numbers it's not scouting it's it's
belief I think that's what it came down
to in Washington the Dodgers at the
trade deadline you know you got Dozier
who I love that pickup for them I
thought that was a great sneaky little
pickup obviously Machado gets the
headlines but where did the Dodgers now
stand
are they the team to beat in the
National League definitely definitely I
mean the fact that they had the most
terrible first two months of the season
you could possibly imagine
for a team with that talent level and
coming into the deadline in a pretty
tough division we're already in first
place and then added the single best
player available at the deadline and
kind of the sneaky sleeper best player
and Brian Dozier
I mean you've now got what I guess 70
home run middle infield essentially
lining goes to go with that deep
pitching staff yeah I mean the first two
months are forgotten out there the
favorite you know still gotta like the
Nationals I do the Cubs but I mean we
could be looking at a rematch from last
October which really wouldn't be a bad
thing no well it's pretty great World
Series but if I get had an open draft
and you had to offer somebody five-year
contract so you got the first pick open
draft play Mike Trout right is not a
trick to a question is it okay okay is
it that easy I think it's definitely
that easy for sure
I mean nobody's going to notice because
the Angels have fallen
so far but he's on his way to again one
of the great seasons of all time and
again a season in which he's not gonna
win a playoff game not gonna make the
playoffs again it's a problem for
baseball obviously yeah you know people
don't see him he's playing late at night
and most look for most of the country
he's not playing in October as Rob
Manfred said he doesn't have like a huge
personality but really I mean it's time
to appreciate Mike Trout we are seeing
an absolute legend every single day
right but if I compare these numbers to
prior players Mike trout's numbers are
great today mm-hmm but compared to the
Great's of yesterday he's not on par
with them depends how you look at it
he's not on par with Willie Mays or
Mickey Mantle with with what they did or
you throw in Ted Williams now he's a
better better fielder and he can run but
nobody's paying for bases stolen bases
anymore well you know I was talking to
Jeanne Martinez the other day actually
about why he did not get a bigger
contract here he is he's threatening for
the Triple Crown he's been incredible
he's a five-year 110 million dollar
contract which for me is a lot of money
but on baseball terms that's nothing
he's aborted that and he said his
understanding was that everybody does
want to pay for the five-tool guys now
he's like I can't I'm not a great
fielder I don't run all I do what I do
is in the box so I do think that
baseball is actually have a has an
understanding of the value of those
other skills speed but the game is about
I throw hard you swing hard yeah that's
the game right I think the idea is
there's a lot of people who can do that
that you can maybe get some
differentiation with the guys who can
track down a ball in the outfield still
your base like if everybody can hit for
power if everybody can throw strikeouts
where do you get an edge maybe it's in
those athletic guys like Mike Trapp but
you also have if I said the open draft
and let's take trout out of it mm-hmm
you got somebody for the next five years
who you take hmm you got to take my guy
judge know who's your guy Mookie Betts
yeah that's a good pick I love Mookie
yeah
well see another one another five two
guys so you're picking the you know
Mookie Betts is yes he hits for power he
hits when I grew up in an era with the
five-tool guy and
and that I love watching that but but
baseball fans don't you know nobody's
bunting nobody's hitting to the you know
opposite side of the infield move a
runner over that's my biggest problem
with baseball is there is no movement
yeah yeah I mean you know it's it's
treated as a strange event when somebody
like bunts against the [ __ ] like dad
what's that that's that's a bunch son
but could somebody go like the the
Royals did or the Cardinals did back in
the 80s where you did a completely
different your approach was different
yeah I mean well that's kind of what the
Royals did to win a couple years ago
right yeah I mean and that's what the
Giants did as well that was kind of in
vogue for a while you know speed and
defense and station-to-station
it's past say now but baseball runs in
cycles maybe we'll see that come back
you know when everybody's doing the same
thing is when you do something different
that's essentially what the Astros did
right like that's how they built
themselves into what they are now now
you have eight or ten teams trying to do
exactly what the Astros did there's no
advantage in that anymore
like it's hard there's only one number
one overall pick so everybody's tanking
gunning for that you know they're not
gonna get it they're not all gonna be
able to rebuild themselves as the Aster
is did you're gonna try and have to try
to figure out a new way forward
give me the sneaky team that shouldn't
win the World Series would could win the
World Series this year no in five years
Ben well I mean if it's not the
Nationals I think I don't know sneak it
is but the Indians I think right I mean
nobody's talking about them underneath
the three super powers and the a Li is
that because the in Cleveland yet
they're in Cleveland you know like the
Yankees and Red Sox are the Yankees and
Red Sox the Astros are now the Astros
after last year Cleveland kind of
started off slow but when you look at
this team they're as dangerous as
anybody I wouldn't have said that
perhaps before they traded for Brad hand
that was the perfect trade the perfect
deadline move this team needed a
dominant reliever as Andrew Miller is
not healthy you know he's not what he
was a couple years ago and then got the
best one on the market and they traded
their best prospect for it like that's
the ideal Platonic ideal of a deadline
trade but you look at this team I mean
you think about
flute superstars even if you don't think
of them as such Francisco Lindor Jose
Ramirez
I mean legitimate MVP candidate somebody
who is essentially utility infielder a
couple years ago
I mean terrific team I can assure you
that nobody wants to face them in
October
why don't we we can talk about Mike
Trout that your superstar doesn't really
he's not a national superstar you got
these kids in Cleveland and there's no
promotional value attached to them at
all right a mookie betts gets it because
he plays with the Red Sox
you know if Mookie Betts played for
Pittsburgh we might look at him the way
we did Andrew McCutchen like oh you know
he's a really talented player wonder
where he's gonna be next year all right
you know when they can't afford him here
but you know that's part of the problem
too with baseball you do have these
markets you know the Yankees are always
going to promote but you know it's the
whole league that it feels like they
don't know how to promote these players
they don't know how to promote teams and
it feels like we focus in on the same
teams in the same players I still think
a few years later they're battling a bit
of a Jeter hangover right like Jeter
carried so much water for them as far as
being the face of the league as far as
being the superstar for so long that
underneath him there was less motivation
to kind of develop the next wave and now
he retires and they've been struggling
with it for several years now how do you
think Jeter's gonna do in that job in
Florida he long in the pub my magic
8-balls a little hazy look I'm actually
impressed I think it's gotten better so
far than I thought it would you know I
thought this team was gonna be an
absolute disaster but I mean he was
talking a lot about these intangible
things that I write about so now they're
just a disaster they're not an absolute
to say there's not I don't even know if
they're a disaster like they're just
they're kind of rebuilding but they're
not interesting they're not interesting
that's true but he was talking a lot
about these intangibles like Drive and
like all these Clubhouse things that a
lot of people are scoffing and remember
when he got upset with Bryant Gumbel
where Brian talked about exactly
thinking and and Jeter got upset about
it you know those guys play hard it's
it's front-office tanking you take the
big names out you trade them away
of course you put
on the field and they're playing hard
but you are tanking its it just comes
from the management and the product you
put on the field not how hard you're
playing on the field yeah I mean they do
seem to have some sort of spirit in that
clubhouse it's allowing them to play
better than the sum of their parts which
is not something they had for you know
eight years before that you know I did a
story on John Khalistan when he came to
the Yankees and he was telling me I just
wanted stability it was eight different
managers eight different hitting coaches
you know we had to wear suits on the
road we couldn't wear suits on the road
you know we had could have facial hair
we couldn't have facial hair all the way
through we think oh that stuff silly it
doesn't matter I think that cultural
stuff really does matter that's
something that the Astros certainly
understood in part why they brought on
Carlos Beltran last year I think that's
something that Jeter does understand
perhaps on an intuitive level the lot of
stats people might not the book is Astro
ball and the writer has been writer
Sports Illustrated senior writer the new
way to win it all we appreciate you
joining us Ben good luck with the book
thank you thanks Dan for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]